Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Etats-Unis, Chine et Europe,
vers une écologie de guerre ?
La décarbonation
de l'économie est au coeur
des échanges commerciaux mondiaux
et des relations internationales.
C'est à juste titre que l'on parle
d'écologie de guerre
au regard de la compétition
effrénée que se livrent
les Etats-Unis et la Chine
dans le domaine de l'industrie
et des technologies vertes.
Qu'on en juge,
le président Joe Biden a injecté
sous l'appellation sibylline d'IRA
ou Inflation Reduction Act
l'octroi de 369 milliards
de dollars pour booster
l'économie et l'industrie
américaines décarbonées.
A la vérité, du dumping écologique
pour relocaliser sur place
les industries liées
aux énergies propres
et à l'automobile.
La Chine n'est pas en reste
pour la domination mondiale
en matière de transition écologique
avec des performances
exceptionnelles
sinon dominatrice sur le marché
des énergies renouvelables,
notamment les panneaux solaires,
des terres et métaux rares
et dans la fabrication des batteries
au lithium, composant essentiel
de la voiture électrique.
Et l'Europe, me direz-vous ?
Elle possède aussi son sigle,
le NZIA,
ou Net Zero Industry Act,
vous voyez, c'est aussi en anglais,
des investissements importants
pour renforcer
l'éventail de ses technologies
vertes, mais elle est
toujours à la recherche
d'une unité d'action.
Parce qu'elle fait face
à des dissensions,
essentiellement
franco-allemandes,
et cela hypothèque l'efficacité
d'un éventuel fonds européen
de souveraineté écologique
qui tarde à se concrétiser.
Nous allons chercher à comprendre
les tenants et les aboutissants,
les aboutissements, pardon,
de cette écologie de conquête
à base de rivalité commerciale.
Et nous allons le faire
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Anne Lauvergeon,
vous êtes dirigeante d'entreprise.
Je rappelle que vous avez dirigé
l'entreprise Areva,
aujourd'hui Orano, et que
vous dirigez, vous êtes présidente
de ALP. Boris Ravignon,
vous êtes maire
de Charleville-Mézières
et président par intérim de l'ADEME.
Olivier Lluansi, associé
PwC Stragegy&.
Christian Saint-Etienne,
vous êtes économiste
et professeur émérite au CNAM.
Vous avez vu cette citation
de Thierry Breton,
commissaire européen,
"Fini la naïveté !
"Maintenant, c'est l'action."
Alors, nous allons en parler.
Nous allons d'abord
aborder cette bataille
commerciale et écologique
en termes stratégiques. Nous
aborderons dans un second plan
la rivalité Chine-Etats-Unis
et pour conclure,
l'Europe et notamment
la position de la France.
Est-ce que vous considérez
que la décarbonation de l'économie
constitue aujourd'hui une urgence
stratégique au sein du concert
des nations ?
Anne Lauvergeon.
-Je crois que, de fait, c'est
effectivement
une préoccupation mondiale.
Elle est alimentée
par les inquiétudes des citoyens.
Par exemple, on a longtemps dit
que la machine européenne était
beaucoup trop lointaine,
pas assez proche
des différents citoyens
des pays, donc
je pense que la préoccupation
sur le changement climatique
est une préoccupation prioritaire,
mais c'est pas la seule.
Et le danger,
c'est de n'avoir plus de politique
que de politique
sur le changement climatique.
Et c'est parfois l'impression
qu'on peut en avoir.
Ce qui me frappe
beaucoup, mais je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion d'y revenir,
c'est autant la Chine
ou les Etats-Unis ont effectivement
pris conscience
après beaucoup de refus
et de négation de l'importance
du changement climatique,
mais ils en ont effectivement
une arme pratique
pour à la fois supporter
leurs entreprises,
pour pouvoir les propulser mieux,
alors qu'au niveau européen,
on a
tendance à en faire quelque chose
qui est une sorte de punition
parfois un peu collective,
d'interdictions,
de mise en place de mécanismes
très compliqués, la taxe carbone...
-On va rentrer...
-De systèmes très lourds alors même
que des deux autres côtés,
Chine et Etats-Unis,
ils ont tendance
à développer des politiques
en faveur de leurs entreprises
au premier chef. Donc je dirais
que la façon d'interpréter
la priorité climatique est
très différente
dans les trois ensembles
que l'on voit.
-On va rentrer
dans le détail. On va aborder
tous les aspects.
-Ce qu'on constate aussi,
c'est que le multilatéralisme,
qui a été
une grande tendance depuis
les années 60 jusqu'aux années 2000,
avec la création de l'OMC,
avec l'idée qu'effectivement,
on trouverait
des politiques communes,
on voit aujourd'hui un retour
aux politiques de blocs.
Quelle est ta puissance de feu
pour que tes idées passent ?
Et c'est vrai
que cette tendance
est très profonde.
On voit que l'OMC, après l'échec
du cycle de Doha se retrouve
un peu le bec dans l'eau
sur à peu près tous les sujets.
-Vous êtes d'accord
sur cette approche-là,
Boris Ravignon ?
-Une petite nuance.
Je crois quand même qu'on a
l'habitude, nous, Européens,
de se flageller. Sur ce sujet-là,
ceux qui sont cohérents,
rationnels avec l'objectif
d'arriver à décarboner
l'ensemble de nos activités
pour éviter le drame climatique,
parce que ce qu'on commence à voir
nous donne un avant-goût
de ce que le monde pourrait devenir
si nous n'avons pas
des politiques climatiques
sérieuses. Les seuls qui les aient,
avec des trajectoires calées
sur l'objectif de neutralité carbone
à l'horizon 2050, c'est l'Europe.
C'est les seuls, les autres
comprennent que le monde évolue
dans ce sens-là
et y voient des opportunités, ce que
nous, nous n'arrivons pas
encore complètement à faire.
Il faut quand même,
sur le fait qu'on ait, nous,
avec l'Accord de Paris,
eu une stratégie cohérente
pour décarboner l'économie,
ce qui est indispensable
à la survie de l'espèce humaine
sur la planète, je crois
qu'il faut pas s'en flageller.
Par contre,
je partage le fait qu'aujourd'hui,
nous ne sommes pas encore
du tout organisés
pour en faire une formidable
opportunité de réindustrialisation
de nos territoires,
de développement,
de la maîtrise de technologies
que nous avons par ailleurs.
-C'est juste un premier constat
que je vous demandais,
est-ce que
Christian Saint-Etienne,
Olivier Lluansi, vous considérez
que c'est une priorité, j'imagine,
mais je vais vous laisser répondre ?
Et sur la distinction
faite par Anne Lauvergeon,
c'est plus abstrait de notre côté,
c'est plus commercial ailleurs.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Mais on rentrera
dans le détail, si vous voulez.
Juste là, une première approche.
-Je suis obligé
d'être d'accord avec Anne
sur le fait que la stratégie
européenne écologique,
qui est souhaitable,
mais elle est punitive d'abord,
est très réglementaire
et qu'elle ne promeut pas
les entreprises européennes.
Et surtout, elle oublie
ce qui se passe
au niveau mondial.
Si on regarde à l'horizon 2025,
la Chine représentera 35 %
des émissions de CO2 en 2025
et l'Europe, 7 %.
Et quand on regarde les débats
en Europe, on a l'impression
que l'Europe fait 70 %
des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
-Il faut rappeler
qu'il y a 1 milliard
400 millions d'habitants en Chine
et qu'en Europe, on est
autour de 450 millions.
-On est d'accord, mais ceci étant,
si on considère la terre
comme un écosystème intégré,
il faut regarder
les sources quel que soit
le nombre d'habitants.
Et l'Europe est un acteur,
on a l'impression
que c'est le principal émetteur,
il faut juste
rappeler les chiffres.
La Chine toute seule,
c'est 7 fois
à l'horizon de 2 ou 3 ans,
7 fois les émissions de CO2
de l'Europe, l'Inde suit.
A l'horizon 2030, l'Asie,
c'est les deux tiers des émissions
de CO2 au plan mondial.
Donc je trouve
qu'au niveau européen,
on est trop dans le punitif,
l'autopunitif et pas assez
dans la promotion
des acteurs stratégiques européens.
Il y a pas que sur l'écologie.
Sur le numérique
et sur tous les sujets.
-Olivier Lluansi,
sur cette distinction
qui est faite aujourd'hui ?
-Est-ce que c'est
un sujet central ? Oui.
Comme M. Ravignon vient de le dire,
on commence à en sentir, je dirais,
pas simplement les mesures
par des scientifiques,
mais aussi des épisodes
climatiques aigus,
qui nous impactent
et le feront de plus en plus.
Le dérèglement climatique et la
question du carbone sont critiques.
Sur le champ de l'environnement,
et j'irai pas très loin,
peut-être d'autres personnes
ici sauront plus,
encore une fois, il n'y a pas
que le dérèglement climatique,
il y a des problèmes d'eau, de sol,
qui sont un peu écrasés
par le sujet décarbonation.
Ca veut pas dire
qu'il est pas important.
Si on en vient
sur le plan économique
et qui va réussir
à faire cette bataille,
qui va réussir
à mettre sur le marché
les équipements nécessaires
à trouver la part technologique
des solutions, il y aura aussi
une part comportementale
de notre façon de consommer,
on est dans une guerre.
C'est pas la seule.
On l'a sur les puces électroniques,
sur les produits pharmaceutiques,
sur la gestion
de la donnée, etc. Et dans cette
bataille, malgré l'affirmation
qui était votre point d'introduction
du commissaire européen,
la naïveté ne semble pas
avoir disparu et on reste,
quand on fait
la liste de ces sujets,
qui sont des sujets de souveraineté
environnementale, je dirais,
pharmaceutique, de données,
on reste quand même
sur une approche qui reste
très, je dirais, modérée en termes
de volontarisme au niveau européen.
Mais on pourra y revenir
avec des chiffres.
-Vous êtes dirigeant,
un des dirigeants de PwC
et, à ce titre,
vous connaissez bien l'industrie.
La question qui se pose, c'est
que l'année 2022
a enregistré un record
des émissions mondiales
de carbone, mais en même temps,
une accélération
des consommations d'énergie
et notamment de l'électricité,
peut-être que les deux choses
sont liées,
mais en même temps, on observe
des investissements très importants
dans les technologies
et l'industrie vertes.
Que faut-il envisager
de plus aujourd'hui
pour enrayer la hausse
de la température ?
Et faire diminuer
ces émissions de carbone ?
-Alors, c'est
une politique globale, moi, je suis
sur l'industrie. L'industrie,
c'est 20 % des émissions,
déjà. Il faut
pas oublier qu'il y a 80 ailleurs.
-Prenez votre part.
-Je prends ma part. En plus,
je vais déborder sur l'autre.
L'industrie aujourd'hui, je vais
prendre l'approche française,
il y a de l'argent qui a été mis
sur la table, c'est considérable,
j'étais encore en conférence
téléphonique avec des investisseurs
dans la pharmacie, ils veulent
décarboner leurs processus.
On a fait la comparaison des
pays européens et des dispositifs,
nous avons avec France 2030
au moins sur le papier le dispositif
le plus puissant
pour accompagner les entreprises
à la décarbonation
en termes de chiffres.
C'est indéniable. Ensuite,
c'est un processus qui va
surtout s'appliquer
aux processus industriels,
la partie du carbone qui est émis
pendant la fabrication.
Si vous me demandez
ce qu'il faudrait
faire de plus pour l'industrie,
il faudrait
élargir ce champ. La 1re chose,
c'est accompagner les industriels
à la conception,
l'écoconception de produits,
qui sont certes économes
pendant leur fabrication en énergie
et en émission de carbone,
qui le sont aussi
pendant leur usage et également
pendant leur fin de vie. Tout ce
volet d'écoconception des produits,
on est dans un monde qui change,
plein de choses changent,
va nous amener à réinventer
tous nos objets
du quotidien. La voiture est
un exemple avec l'électrique.
Mais c'est pas le seul
et là, aujourd'hui,
dans notre façon de voir les choses,
on n'est pas encore
remontés à la source,
comment on réinvente
les produits, qui nous permet
d'avoir moins de carbone
pendant leur production,
leur utilisation,
leur fin de vie et qui utilise
des matériaux
qui nous rendent moins dépendants,
des compétences disponibles en
France en étant compétitives, etc.
Cet exercice de réflexion profond
sur la conception n'est pas lancé.
-Boris Ravignon, quid de l'industrie
ou que faut-il faire ailleurs
pour faire baisser...
-On a un exercice de prospective
à l'ADEME, qui s'appelle Transition
2050. On regarde plusieurs scénarios
pour atteindre justement
la neutralité carbone.
Les éléments de base
de ces scénarios,
c'est d'abord,
partout où on le peut,
de baisser
nos consommations d'énergie.
Donc il y a,
Olivier Lluansi parlait
d'une dimension comportementale,
ce qu'on appelle la sobriété,
cette interrogation
qu'on a sur est-ce que j'ai besoin
d'utiliser ma voiture pour faire
300 m aller chercher le pain ?
Est-ce que j'ai besoin
d'avoir un grand appartement ?
Tout ce qui touche au comportement
est une part importante pour baisser
la consommation par la sobriété.
On a ensuite des technologies
qui améliorent l'efficacité,
le même service, mais par contre,
on utilise moins d'énergie
et il reste une partie de l'énergie
qu'il faut effectivement décarboner.
Pour l'essentiel,
le travail qu'on a à faire,
c'est de développer
des énergies qui vont produire
une électricité renouvelable. Ca
peut être du nucléaire, ça peut être
dans le cas des différents scénarios
un développement
considérable des énergies
renouvelables, éolienne, solaire
et différentes variétés d'éolien,
la géothermie, etc.
En fait, en même temps,
c'est pour ça qu'on va vivre
dans les années
à venir,
si on tient bien nos objectifs,
une baisse de consommation,
on a déjà commencé
avec la sobriété énergétique
cet hiver par exemple,
et une augmentation
de la consommation
et donc nécessairement
de la production d'électricité.
La part de l'électricité
dans notre consommation d'énergie
va avoir tendance à augmenter,
car l'électricité décarbone
en grande partie nos usages.
-Christian Saint-Etienne,
je vous place d'emblée
une casquette d'économiste.
Et donc vous avez rappelé
que ce que fait
l'Europe, les Etats-Unis ou
la Chine, c'est pas la même chose.
Mais dans ces émissions
de carbone qui grimpent,
quelle est la part relative
de responsabilité, si vous voulez,
dans cette élévation
de température ?
-Le logement
et le transport sont des éléments
clés de la carbonation.
Mais...
-Mais un Africain pèse que dalle
si je puis dire.
-Alors, ça change très rapidement.
L'Inde, qui était...
-L'Inde, c'est pas
l'Afrique,
même si c'est la première population
mondiale.
-La population
africaine va doubler.
Elle a déjà massivement augmenté.
Elle va
vers 2 milliards d'habitants.
Les deux secteurs
de l'économie mondiale sur le plan
démographique où on a une croissance
forte, c'est l'Afrique noire,
donc du côté de l'Afrique,
et les pays musulmans d'Asie avec
des taux de fécondité des femmes
en Afghanistan et au Pakistan
qui sont supérieurs à 5 encore.
Donc c'est
dans ces pays-là qu'on a
une progression très importante
de la population.
Mais la Chine ne s'est pas engagée
à baisser ses émissions,
mais à baisser
la production d'émissions de CO2
par unité d'augmentation
de PIB. Donc c'est un peu
l'efficacité énergétique,
mais elle s'est pas engagée
à baisser la quantité de CO2
qu'elle émet.
Sur la question centrale,
si on veut vraiment aller
vers une croissance
économique décarbonée,
il faut électrifier le système.
Ca suppose de doubler la production
électrique. Ce qui m'inquiète,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de projet
actuellement de doublement.
L'énergie nucléaire
ne fera pas
le job.
-On va en parler.
-Mais en termes globaux,
si on veut doubler la production
électrique sur 20 ans,
les premières centrales nucléaires
seront opérationnelles
dans 15 ans. Si on doit passer
de 100 à 200 en termes
de production électrique,
les centrales nucléaires
amèneront peut-être
15 à 20...
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-La question centrale, c'est
est-ce qu'on est sérieux, parce que,
si on veut éliminer
le charbon et le pétrole,
il y a pas de vie
économique, sociale
et politique sans énergie.
-Anne Lauvergeon,
je voudrais qu'on avance
un petit peu dans ce sujet.
La pandémie
de Covid
comme la guerre en Ukraine
ont montré la dépendance extérieure,
de notre pays,
mais de tous les pays
pour la production de biens,
de technologies,
de ressources indispensables
à la consommation.
On a vu les troubles économiques
et sociaux que ça génère.
Est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à un protectionnisme
économique et écologique ?
Autrement dit, la barrière carbone ?
Ou faire quelque chose,
parce qu'on peut pas rester...
La compétition est faussée,
en quelque sorte,
si on ne se protège pas.
-Alors, c'est vrai
qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans une ambiance générale
qu'a activé le Covid.
Parce que ça a été le révélateur
pour beaucoup de pays
de la dépendance
sur les produits pharmaceutiques,
mais sur beaucoup d'autres choses
de la Chine. Donc
il y a une sorte de... On a
longtemps été plus des consommateurs
que des citoyens finalement
sur tous ces sujets.
Et on s'est réveillé
avec deux choses
qui sont parfois
un peu antagonistes,
d'une part la nécessité
effectivement de décarboner,
d'être beaucoup plus attentifs
à l'environnement,
et puis, de l'autre,
une autre notion
que beaucoup avaient oubliée,
la sécurité.
Sécurité énergétique,
sécurité alimentaire, tout ce qui
paraissait, sécurité pharmaceutique,
tout ce qui paraissait
absolument évident.
Quelque part,
l'électricité, ça sort du mur.
Enfin, il y a aucun problème.
On s'est
réveillé un petit peu avec,
bah oui, cette dimension-là,
elle existe aussi.
Et là on en revient à la naïveté
européenne, qui considérait
qu'on n'avait qu'à acheter
sur étagères quelque part
et on trouverait ce qu'on veut.
On se réveille dans un monde
beaucoup plus complexe où sécurité
et environnement sont deux choses
qui vont pas forcément de pair
ensemble et les deux, on va devoir
les mener. Rappelez-vous cet hiver,
quand les Français ont entendu
parler et les Allemands
et le reste de l'Europe
de coupures d'électricité.
Or force est de constater
que nous allons
depuis une bonne quinzaine d'années
vers toujours plus d'électricité
et comme le disait Christian,
c'est la façon de décarboner
si on produit
cette électricité de manière propre,
c'est la façon
de décarboner l'économie.
Mais cette électricité,
comment la produire ?
Si vous suivez
la Commission européenne,
il faut qu'en 2030,
on ait 42,5 %
de renouvelable. 42,5 %
de renouvelable, ça sort d'où, ça ?
On sait pas. Bon.
On a perdu énormément de temps
en querelles théologiques
en France, idéologique,
et en Europe, lutte antinucléaire,
les gens qui étaient
antirenouvelable, tout ça
est complètement dépassé.
Et ce qui m'inquiète
personnellement,
c'est qu'on continue à,
par exemple, la décision
qui a été prise à l'unanimité
des Etats membres
qu'en 2035 on n'aurait plus
de moteurs thermiques,
donc on n'aurait plus
que des moteurs électriques,
désolée de le dire,
il n'y a pas eu de vraie étude
pour savoir si on avait
les capacités électriques.
Les capacités électriques,
on pourrait les avoir,
mais on n'a pas
la puissance électrique
derrière. C'est
de la physique un peu avancée,
mais si vous voulez charger votre
voiture, il faut de la puissance.
Nous n'avons pas la puissance
électrique d'ici 2035 disponible
pour remplacer l'ensemble
des moteurs thermiques.
C'est bien beau
d'avoir des idées généreuses,
formidable,
on renonce aux horribles
moteurs thermiques,
qui ont permis beaucoup
de choses, et les remplacer
par des moteurs électriques,
alors qu'on n'en a pas
les moyens physiques.
-Je voudrais
que vous donniez l'explication
pour les téléspectateurs
cette chose-là.
La Chine envisage
de développer
une très grosse usine de batteries
en Europe.
On sait bien qu'elle domine
déjà dans le domaine des batteries.
Est-ce que ça a
le même effet
si elle nous exporte ses batteries
qui sont indispensables
pour le véhicule électrique
ou si elle les fabrique
chez nous ?
Est-ce que...
Autrement dit, est-ce qu'il y a pas
une politique protectionniste
à avoir
à l'égard de la Chine
dans un domaine
aussi stratégique ?
On est tous favorables
à la décarbonation, on sait
que l'électrique
va se développer et là,
on se retrouve devant quasiment
un fait commercial accompli.
-Les méga-usines de batteries,
on en voit une quantité incroyable.
Toutes ne vont pas se réaliser
et elles se réaliseront d'ailleurs
dans les pays où l'électricité
est la moins chère.
L'électricité est
la moins chère où, aujourd'hui ?
En Norvège, dans le nord
de la Suède, c'était en France,
ça ne l'est plus.
Ca, c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation. Et puis, ces usines,
ces méga-usines batteries,
il va falloir les remplir
avec un certain nombre
de matières premières,
de matières premières
transformées. Et ça,
le pipe amont, on l'a pas.
Donc ça, c'est aussi un sujet.
Il y a pas de politique européenne
sur les matières premières,
alors que la Chine est
obsédée par le sujet. Alors,
la méga-usine de batteries chinoise,
elle est très intelligente.
Ils ont raison
de la promouvoir. Pourquoi il faut
la faire en Europe aussi ?
Ca permettrait, s'il y avait un jour
une législation européenne,
comme il est
en train de se mettre
en place aux Etats-Unis,
s'il faut que les batteries soient
fabriquées en Europe
pour qu'il y ait
des subventions...
-On dépendra
quand même de la Chine.
-Bien sûr.
Prenez Hyundai,
Hyundai avait zéro usine
aux Etats-Unis.
Il y a l'IRA qui se met en place.
Il faut fabriquer aux Etats-Unis
pour que le consommateur,
l'acheteur ait 7500 dollars
et des avantages fiscaux,
des carottes
qui sont mises en place, etc.
Hyundai vient de décider d'investir
11 milliards de dollars
aux Etats-Unis, ils avaient pas
d'usine, ils en font
une aux Etats-Unis pour faire
des voitures aux Etats-Unis.
Les Chinois
ne sont pas du tout idiots.
Stratégiquement, c'est du jeu de go.
Les Européens vont mettre le temps.
Peut-être qu'ils vont se dire
qu'il faut mettre des carottes
pour pousser
leurs industries nationales.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On met
une usine de batteries chinoises
et on pourra vendre
des voitures chinoises,
même s'il y a des embargos.
-Olivier Lluansi.
-Vous avez posé la question de
la dépendance ou de l'indépendance.
On peut lister une série
de sujets stratégiques
et ils sont déjà apparus ici.
Il y a les équipements
pour la transition écologique,
pour la mobilité, pour la pharmacie,
les puces électroniques
ou le stockage de données.
Même si le monde va
vers des tensions géopolitiques
beaucoup plus renforcées
qu'avant, il est illusoire
de croire qu'on sera totalement
indépendants même à l'échelle
européenne. La véritable bataille,
c'est de choisir nos dépendances
et nos points forts.
Aujourd'hui, la Chine transforme
plus de 80 %
de tous les métaux stratégiques,
fournit plus de 80 %
des batteries
et avec l'Inde, fournissent
80 % des molécules actives
pour notre pharmacie.
Les Etats-Unis ont 80 %
de la propriété sur le design
des puces, contrôlent tout ce qui
est de la donnée et du stockage.
Ces deux ensembles-là
sont capables
de créer une interdépendance
qui leur permettra
peut-être d'aller
trop loin. Dans ces équilibres-là,
l'Europe n'a rien
où on pourrait dire
80 % de cet objet-là,
ce service-là stratégique
est détenu par l'Europe.
Fut un temps
le nucléaire était une spécialité
européenne, française, aujourd'hui,
ce n'est plus le cas,
on a perdu de la distance,
de l'innovation.
Quelles sont les interdépendances
que l'on veut créer ?
Encore une fois, une indépendance
pure n'existe pas, est illusoire
On ne parle
ni d'autonomie ni d'autarcie.
Même si de temps en temps...
Et sur le protectionnisme,
je pose une question simple.
Nous subventionnons
avec le bonus automobile,
bonus voiture électrique,
des voitures qui sont de partout
et qu'on voit débarquer des voitures
d'origine chinoise,
que les Etats-Unis ont décidé
de limiter ce type de bonus
à des voitures produites
aux Etats-Unis
avec des critères un peu stricts.
Je pense que nos concitoyens
ne vont pas tarder à réagir
et nos politiques derrière.
Donc je pense qu'effectivement,
on va avoir une tendance
à une certaine forme
de protectionnisme qu'il va falloir
assumer, mais encore une fois,
dans quelle stratégie,
avec quels objectifs,
quelles technologies maîtriser,
quelles dépendances accepter ?
-Boris Ravignon.
-On va dans les années à venir
investir massivement
dans tous les équipements
de la transition énergétique.
La Commission européenne dit,
sur les technologies
de la transition,
c'est autour de 600 milliards
d'euros par an.
C'est considérable.
Les chiffres de l'IEA,
l'Agence internationale
de l'Energie,
sont encore plus importants,
mais rien que sur les technologies,
600 milliards dans le monde.
Et ça, il est crucial,
absolument vital, pour l'Europe,
que l'essentiel
de ces investissements soient
des investissements qui l'aident
à conforter sa souveraineté.
On pourrait discuter très longtemps
de souveraineté. Vous noterez que
décarboner notre industrie, c'est
sortir tous les fossiles
de notre balance commerciale,
ça va nous mettre
dans une situation
de souveraineté énergétique
quasi totale.
A 2050, il y a plus de gaz fossile
et plus de pétrole,
donc on est à 100 %
de souveraineté énergétique,
mais il ne faut pas troquer
une dépendance contre une autre.
Et la dépendance est technologique.
Le sujet est de savoir
d'où viendront les panneaux solaires
qu'on va installer.
Aujourd'hui, 90
% viennent effectivement
de Chine. 90 %, le marché
des cellules photovoltaïques,
c'est la Chine.
Et c'est pas arrivé tout seul.
Ce que dit le commissaire
Breton sur la naïveté, je crois pas
qu'on s'en soit guéris
et surtout,
elle dure depuis longtemps.
Il y a eu une industrie, notamment
en Allemagne du panneau solaire,
elle a été tuée,
assassinée par les Chinois
qui avec un dumping
effréné faisaient que les panneaux
qui arrivaient en Europe...
-Il faut les laisser venir ?
-Bien sûr que non. C'est pour ça
qu'à mon sens,
il y a deux évolutions
indispensables,
l'une sur les aides d'Etat.
Il faut pouvoir aider
davantage nos industriels.
Et une autre
sur la protection aux frontières
qui est embryonnaire
-Christian Saint-Etienne,
une question
un peu idéologique. D'un côté,
il y a des économies libérales,
de l'autre côté,
des économies illibérales,
en tout cas autoritaires.
Est-ce que le jeu n'est pas
faussé de la concurrence ?
-Bien sûr que le jeu est faussé.
Quand la Chine est entrée
à l'OMC en 2001,
les Américains s'y étaient opposés
pendant les 15 années précédentes,
ils ont été bernés
par la réponse chinoise
au 11-septembre,
ils ont cru que les Chinois allaient
accompagner la politique américaine
de lutte contre un certain nombre
d'Etats considérés comme terroristes
par les Américains, mais la raison
pour laquelle les Américains
s'y opposaient, c'est qu'il y avait
deux volets de l'OMC
avec des protocoles que
les Chinois ne voulaient pas signer.
D'abord, l'ouverture des marchés
publics. Il a fallu attendre
Juncker il y a 5 ans ou 4 ans, pour
qu'il dise, tiens, c'est quand même
gênant que 90 %
des marchés publics européens
soient ouverts aux Chinois,
alors que 2 % des marchés chinois
sont ouverts
aux Européens. Là, il y a des règles
qu'il faut mettre en place.
Beaucoup de spécialistes
sur ces questions disent qu'il faut
avoir une politique commerciale
ouverte certes,
mais basée sur la réciprocité.
Si le marché chinois
de la commande publique est
fermé, il faut fermer
le marché européen.
On sait
pourquoi ça ne s'est pas fait.
Parce que le leadership,
peut-être l'aborderons-nous,
mais le leadership politique
en Europe a basculé en faveur
de l'Allemagne
il y a une dizaine d'années en lien
avec notre désindustrialisation.
Et la France a beaucoup de défauts,
mais pendant la longue période
où elle a été très influente,
elle a mené une politique européenne
pour l'Europe.
L'Allemagne mène
une politique allemande en Europe
extrêmement mercantiliste.
Donc les Allemands ont accepté
le harakiri de leur industrie
de panneaux photovoltaïques, car,
en contrepartie
ils vendaient des voitures
et des machines-outils en Chine.
Ils voient que les Chinois vont
les supplanter sur l'automobile
et qu'ils sont devenus
très bons en machines-outils,
donc il se peut
que les Allemands bougent,
mais avec 20 ans de retard.
Effectivement, ça n'a pas de sens,
je me bats exactement comme Boris
sur le fait que produire
de l'électricité
avec des panneaux photovoltaïques
importés de Chine,
c'est complètement con.
A un moment, il faut avoir
un minimum de cohérence
sur le plan stratégique. Et ce qui
est encore plus irritant, c'est que,
je termine par là,
le CEA a développé
des technologies
de panneaux photovoltaïques,
Enel construit une usine
géante de panneaux photovoltaïques
sur la base
de cette technologie en Sicile,
qu'est-ce qu'on fout ?
Pourquoi il n'y a pas
une politique stratégique française
sur ces sujets ?
-Alors là, vous venez de voir
la citation
de Geoffroy Roux de Bézieux,
patron du MEDEF,
mais aujourd'hui
un mandat renouvelé.
"Nous n'avons pas le choix,
l'Europe doit s'aligner
"sur le niveau
des subventions américaines."
Les Etats-Unis disposent,
on l'a dit,
de près de 400 milliards
de dollars avec l'IRA,
l'Europe dit avec son sigle NZIA,
Net Zero
Industry Act, qu'elle va mettre
beaucoup d'argent. On parle
d'un fonds de souveraineté. On est
très loin, très loin, d'une parité
en termes d'investissement.
Qu'en pensez-vous, Olivier Lluansi ?
-Il y a plusieurs éléments.
D'abord, il y a des chiffres
qui se confrontent. L'Europe dit :
si, j'ai 400 milliards à mettre.
C'est sans doute vrai, mais plutôt
en amont du cycle sur l'innovation
et sur la recherche,
cela n'aide pas la production.
Or l'une des spécificités
de l'Inflation Reduction Act,
c'est bien pour cibler
la production elle-même,
aider à ce qu'elle...
-Donc il y a beaucoup
plus d'argent ?
-Non, on compare des choses
qui sont pas comparables.
C'est la première chose.
Finalement, l'Europe,
dans sa grande générosité d'aide,
n'aide pas
la production directement.
Elle le renvoie
aux Etats avec des mécanismes
soit directs soit plus complexes
qu'on appelle des PIEC.
Donc, en fait, la réponse
à l'IRA aujourd'hui, l'Europe dit,
à peu près, tant que j'ai pas
mon fonds qui est prévu pour l'été,
mais ça commence à glisser
sans savoir jusqu'où,
dit, c'est aux Etats
de le faire. Si on prend
l'IRA américain et qu'on le ramène
à la taille française,
il faudrait mettre sur la table
39 milliards d'euros.
C'est une simple règle de trois.
39 milliards d'euros
pour aider nos industries
à développer
des capacités. Alors, la réponse,
c'est, ah, on a déjà France 2030.
Oui, mais dans France 2030,
il y a seulement 17 milliards
d'euros pour aider l'industrie,
les autres, c'est pour la recherche.
Donc 17 milliards versus 39.
Et sur ces 17 milliards,
il y en a que la moitié,
ce qui est déjà énorme,
on est extrêmement
bien dotés sur le sujet,
pour les sujets de décarbonation.
Si je rajoute une couche, je dirais,
ça passe par des concours,
des appels à projets,
ce ne sont pas des aides
automatiques. Ce que les industriels
apprécient avec l'IRA américain,
c'est que c'est
un guichet. Vous déposez,
vous avez le papier d'engagement,
c'est un calcul automatique
et beaucoup
de crédits d'impôt.
Et donc, globalement,
si on met tout ça bout à bout,
on voit qu'il y a
quelque chose d'extrêmement
disproportionné aujourd'hui
entre ce qui est proposé
par les Etats-Unis
et ce qui est en place en Europe
et notamment en France.
-Alors, Anne Lauvergeon, pourquoi
on n'a pas autant de moyens
que les Américains ? Puisque
Olivier Lluansi vient
de nous montrer
que ce que met l'Europe,
c'est des budgets
biaisés, puisqu'ils concernent
la recherche, le développement,
la production.
Pourquoi il y a ce manque ?
-Alors, c'est difficile.
J'ai pas la réponse universelle
sur le sujet,
mais je dirais
que l'approche de l'Europe
est essentiellement
une approche réglementaire,
une approche limitative.
Ce qui vient d'être voté,
c'est un nouveau marché carbone,
un système
très complexe qui va se mettre
en place à partir de 2025, 2026,
pour que tous les produits
importés en Europe
venant de manière extra-européenne,
on puisse compter le carbone
qui a été utilisé pour le produire
et qu'en rentrant en Europe,
ces produits qui peuvent être
très composites,
très complexes, puissent être
effectivement... avoir une taxe.
Notre approche à la fois
réglementaire et taxatrice
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur.
L'approche américaine, elle...
Notre approche,
elle est un peu bâton.
L'approche américaine,
elle est carotte.
Elle est carotte
pour le consommateur. Si vous prenez
un bon produit américain
avec les bonnes caractéristiques,
la voiture électrique
avec la batterie
et le système de vitesses
américains, paf, 7500 dollars.
C'est concret pour le consommateur.
-Nous aussi, on a ça en Europe.
-Ah non !
-Sans l'origine.
-Il n'y a pas d'origine.
Absolument pas.
Le consommateur américain,
il est poussé à acheter américain.
Les entreprises
qui aujourd'hui s'installent
ou sont déjà installées
aux Etats-Unis
ont des crédits d'impôt.
-Ca s'appelle pas
la préférence nationale, ça ?
En économie ?
-On peut l'appeler comme on le veut.
Préférence nationale,
ça a une connotation politique
particulière.
-Préférence
communautaire, ça a fonctionné
dans le domaine agricole.
-Qui était mis à part.
-On pourrait dire, pour rebondir,
seules les voitures
produites en Europe à 60 %
seront éligibles aux primes
pour acquérir
une voiture électrique.
-Pourquoi on le fait pas ?
-C'est l'idéologie
qui a dominé l'Europe.
-C'est peut-être
même pas contre le droit
européen, mais, par pratique,
on pourrait le faire,
c'est des aides aux consommateurs,
on peut le regarder,
c'est une préférence communautaire.
-Comme le disait Christian,
la politique allemande
qui est devenue très forte, on a
une présidente de la Commission
européenne allemande,
la politique allemande
vis-à-vis de la Chine
a toujours été
de faire très attention à la Chine,
puisque c'était une voie de sortie
très importante pour leurs voitures,
pour l'industrie automobile,
mais aussi pour des tas de PME, PMI.
Donc la priorité,
c'était de pas embêter les Chinois.
Quand les Chinois sont arrivés...
Alors, aujourd'hui,
ressusciter une industrie
photovoltaïque en Europe,
c'est vraiment très difficile.
Ca prend du temps
et ça demanderait un effort
colossal. Prenez
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui,
c'est de la dynamique, c'est
maintenant, dans l'éolien.
Nous avons des constructeurs éoliens
européens qui vont pas très bien.
Ils ont des carnets
de commandes significatifs,
mais la hausse des taux d'intérêt,
les problématiques,
ça devient compliqué
de les installer,
ils ont dû se restructurer,
se consolider.
Vous avez aujourd'hui un peu
un marasme. Quand vous regardez les
chiffres, on était à 41 milliards
d'investissements
dans l'éolien
en Europe en 2021,
on est à 17 en 2022.
Il y a une chute significative.
Jusqu'à présent,
les joueurs européens étaient
les plus importants
avec les Etats-Unis.
Aujourd'hui,
celui qui fait égal égal
avec Vestas,
c'est Goldwind en Chine,
c'est un Chinois, qui commence
à exporter de plus en plus
et les industriels
de l'éolien aujourd'hui disent,
attention, en Europe,
il va nous arriver
ce qui est arrivé
au photovoltaïque.
Jusqu'à présent, réaction, rien.
Donc la vitesse aussi
de nos actions ou de nos réactions
est un énorme problème,
parce que, quand vous partez
sur du dumping sauvage, la mort,
je dis la mort, parce que, quand on
dit 90 % de photovoltaïque européen,
non... chinois, c'est beaucoup plus.
Il y a quelques Européens
qui font du montage des Chinois
qui comptent pour Européens,
mais en vérité on est à 97 %, 98 %
de Chinois. Il risque de nous
arriver la même chose dans l'éolien
et notre Commission européenne
dit toujours
42,5 % de renouvelable en 2030.
C'est tout.
-Boris Ravignon.
-Je suis pas économiste,
mais praticien,
je vois ce qui se passe
dans le Grand Est.
On avait sur le site
où s'était implanté Smart,
puis Smart est parti,
la possibilité de faire venir
un producteur indien,
semble-t-il avec d'autres capitaux,
qui s'appelait Rec Solar,
pour implanter une usine
de production de panneaux
photovoltaïques, il a fini
par renoncer à son projet.
Pour une raison toute simple. C'est
qu'il suffit pas d'avoir simplement
des aides pour avoir
une politique industrielle
et des industries, il faut
que le marché
sur lequel on s'implante,
on y bénéficie
d'une certaine protection.
Rec Solar a dit, vous êtes
l'Union européenne,
un marché tellement ouvert
à toutes les importations du monde
que je n'ai aucun intérêt
à venir me localiser ici. Je serai
très bien à continuer à produire
en Inde et à vous les envoyer,
puisque vous n'avez aucune politique
commerciale aux frontières
et surtout pas
de protectionnisme.
Si on veut à la fois avoir
un développement industriel
dans toutes ces technologies,
il y a nécessairement à aider
un certain nombre d'industries
à se développer,
mais à aussi assurer une protection
minimale du marché
avec un ajustement aux frontières.
Celui qui a été voté est un 1er pas,
il faut pas mésestimer la difficulté
qu'il y a à progresser
dans le cadre européen,
mais on est
sur des produits bruts,
de l'aluminium, du ciment,
des aciers. Tout ça va monter
en charge très progressivement,
pas à la hauteur des enjeux.
-Dans le concert des nations,
tout le monde sait
que les nations sont égoïstes
et que chacun
cherche à défendre
son intérêt national.
Mais à votre avis,
Christian Saint-Etienne,
est-ce que l'Union européenne
est tributaire bien souvent
des choix de l'Allemagne
qui dicte le tempo économique
et écologique
et c'est ça qui accroît
la vulnérabilité de l'Europe
dans ce domaine par rapport
à la Chine et aux Etats-Unis ?
Essayez de répondre directement,
parce que le téléspectateur
se pose la question.
-Je pense qu'il y a
une responsabilité allemande
considérable.
Pour les raisons que j'évoquais,
une politique mercantiliste
qui favorise
les entreprises allemandes.
Et il y a
une responsabilité française.
C'est pas les Allemands
qui nous ont conduits au cours
des 15 dernières années à oublier
la politique stratégique énergétique
qu'on avait menée
dans les 40 années qui précèdent.
Si on avait mené
une politique cohérente,
on serait pas
à genoux aujourd'hui.
C'est la même chose
dans d'autres domaines.
Je prends la production
de microprocesseurs.
L'Europe
produisait 20 %
des microprocesseurs dans le monde
il y a 40... 30 ans et on est tombés
à 9 % et on veut revenir à 20.
Sachant qu'en plus, on va produire
des microprocesseurs
de moyenne qualité
en termes de finesse
de la gravure des microprocesseurs,
on va pas produire les dernières
générations. Bon. Sur ce sujet-là,
les Allemands qui ont
beaucoup fauté, comme nous,
ont lancé 4 usines géantes
de fabrication de microprocesseurs.
Nous, nous sommes
sur un projet d'une demi-usine
sur Grenoble avec une opposition
écologiste locale considérable
qui retarde
les investissements.
Sur l'intelligence
artificielle, on vient
d'avoir les chiffres en 2022.
Les Américains,
c'est plus de 40 milliards,
les Chinois, c'est 13 milliards,
les Allemands sont
à 2,5 et la France à 1,5.
On voit que,
sur tous les sujets stratégiques,
on n'investit pas
à la hauteur des enjeux.
Mais je reviens
sur la question qu'on évoquait,
les panneaux photovoltaïques
ou les voitures électriques.
Il y a rien qui nous interdit
dans le droit européen ni à l'OMC
de faire comme les Américains,
donc de dire les aides
aux consommateurs sont données
en contrepartie d'une production
au moins 60 %
sur le territoire européen.
Donc si on le fait pas,
c'est parce que
on n'a pas de vision
de souveraineté européenne réelle.
Et d'ailleurs, les questions
de souveraineté,
les 1res mesures significatives
ont été prises en 2022
après 40 ans de débats
pendant lesquels on n'a rien fait,
alors que les Américains
et les Chinois mènent
des politiques de souveraineté
comme les Indiens,
les Russes, les Brésiliens.
Qu'est-ce qui fait basculer l'Europe
vers une politique de souveraineté ?
Pas de fermeture.
Un dernier point sur ce sujet.
La question de la souveraineté,
elle est étudiée, conduite
en termes de politique
aux Etats-Unis
depuis plus de 60 ans. Tous les
présidents américains produisent
en arrivant au pouvoir
un document de stratégie.
Et ça fait une quarantaine d'années
que les Américains ont dit que la
souveraineté, c'est pas la fermeture
et c'est pas l'autarcie, c'est
d'être autonome sur 6 sujets clés,
qui sont basiques. Pour être
souverain, il faut pouvoir
nourrir son peuple,
donc l'agroalimentaire doit
provenir de son territoire.
Il faut pouvoir
soigner son peuple, donc
la pharmacie est clé.
Nous avions la première industrie
pharmaceutique d'Europe,
on l'a tuée. On est tombés au 4e
ou 5e rang, en dessous de l'Italie,
parce que toute la politique
de santé française
depuis une trentaine d'années,
c'est de taxer
les médicaments, de telle sorte
que les industries sont allées
produire ailleurs.
Il faut nourrir son peuple,
le soigner,
il faut une politique
sur la défense.
Il faut une politique sur l'énergie.
On avait une très belle politique
de l'énergie, on a laissé tomber.
Et il faut
une autonomie sur le numérique.
On voit pas de politique intégrée
au plan européen
sur toutes ces filières.
Il y a des petits débuts
de choses depuis 18 mois
mais après 40 ans d'inaction.
-En écoutant Christian
Saint-Etienne, il vient de nous dire
que tout ne vient pas, tous nos maux
ne viennent pas de l'Allemagne,
mais il y a un sujet qui fait
dissension entre la France
et l'Allemagne, c'est
le nucléaire et notamment
l'impossibilité de déployer
des investissements verts
sur l'hydrogène,
qui viendrait du nucléaire.
Est-ce que vous pensez,
à votre avis,
que, devant cette difficulté,
il faudrait
élargir le tandem franco-allemand
à l'Italie,
ne pas rester, j'allais dire,
acoquiné, si je puis dire,
à cette relation privilégiée ?
Puisqu'elle nous empêche
en quelque sorte
la réindustrialisation.
-Non. Enfin, je pense que...
Je pense comme Christian,
c'est-à-dire il faut pas expliquer
tous nos problèmes par les autres.
Une grosse partie de nos problèmes
viennent de nous-mêmes.
Ce qui m'a toujours tout à fait
étonnée, c'est de voir à quel point,
quand on prend les dirigeants
chinois, les dirigeants américains,
l'obsession qu'ils peuvent avoir
de deux grands sujets,
l'énergie et les matières premières.
Vous regardez
un nouveau président chinois,
il va faire la tournée
de tous les producteurs
de pétrole, de gaz,
en Afrique, par exemple.
L'énergie et les matières premières,
c'est des sujets
absolument primordiaux pour eux.
Or nous avons eu des politiques
historiques en France là-dessus
qui étaient très fortes,
sur le nucléaire,
l'énergie en général,
le fait d'être indépendant
au maximum,
même s'il y avait une dépendance
au pétrole évidemment
et beaucoup aussi au gaz.
Il y avait l'idée de construire
une indépendance nationale.
C'était pas seulement
en termes de moyens de production,
mais c'était l'industrie derrière
qui était capable de fournir.
Matières premières pareil,
BRGM, inventaire
général, ouverture de mines.
Tout ça, terminé.
On est rentrés dans une idée,
ça fait 20, 25 ans que je constate,
qu'effectivement,
l'énergie, bah oui, c'est facile,
tout le monde peut en faire.
-Ca sort du mur.
Les matières premières,
on s'est toujours pas réveillé.
Les matières premières seront
un axe essentiel. Tout le monde
parle de batteries, très bien,
mais c'est plein
de matières premières qui sont
non seulement détenues beaucoup
par la Chine en Chine,
mais vous regardez toute l'Afrique,
il y a des mines un peu partout
de ces métaux rares
détenues par des Chinois
ou avec lesquelles la Chine a
des intérêts commerciaux.
Donc nous sommes dans ces domaines,
alors, on a dit,
il faut faire des renouvelables,
je suis tout à fait pour.
Je me suis battue
pour développer des renouvelables
dans Areva. Deux ministres
des Finances successifs
m'ont dit
que je les décevais beaucoup.
Les renouvelables,
c'est pas sérieux.
Vous croyez pas que les moulins
à vent ont un avenir ?
Donc ce qui est extraordinaire,
c'est qu'on a
développé des politiques
et on ne s'est pas préoccupés
de l'industrialisation
qu'il y avait derrière.
Et ça, c'est extrêmement choquant.
Il y a une sorte
de dichotomie de dire, oui,
on va prôner des nouveaux
équipements, mais sans se préoccuper
de savoir qui va les produire.
Je crois que la France,
et ça, hélas...
Alors, c'est vrai que l'Allemagne
dans sa politique antinucléaire
a été, comment dirais-je,
l'inspiration de beaucoup
d'intellectuels en France,
de beaucoup de journalistes
et c'était une idée reçue
que le nucléaire,
c'était finalement complètement
ringard
et que l'avenir était renouvelable.
Aujourd'hui, on se rend compte
que le nucléaire est bien utile
et a un vrai avenir.
C'est pas la solution, mais il y a
pas de solution sans nucléaire.
C'est une partie de la solution.
Mais on s'aperçoit
qu'on a réussi en 10 ans
à casser le jouet,
mais à le casser de manière
presque systématique. Alors,
il y a une commission d'enquête
parlementaire qui a été
excellemment conduite,
qui a entendu beaucoup de gens,
dont moi. Mais qui a conclu
que c'est 25 ans d'erreur politique.
Et ces 25 ans d'erreur politique
ont été vraiment
absolument dramatiques.
Alors, Areva, par exemple,
couper en deux Areva, aller
donner la construction de réacteurs
à EDF qui a bien des difficultés,
qui en a pas vendu un seul, enlever
les moyens de fonctionnement,
alors que tout le reste
des pays aidaient.
Regardez Westinghouse.
Intéressant, c'est dirigé
par des Français aujourd'hui.
Parce que tous les gens du système
énergétique français sans boulot
sont partis aux Etats-Unis bosser.
Il faut qu'on retrouve le sens.
Il faut arrêter d'accuser les autres
et il faut se dire que nous-mêmes,
il faut qu'on retrouve le sens des
réalités et sortir des idéologies.
Il y en a assez, vous présidez
l'ADEME. L'ADEME a toujours
été antinucléaire.
C'est insupportable.
-Elle ne l'est peut-être pas
aujourd'hui.
On va terminer,
il nous reste très peu de temps.
Le débat est venu
sur la réindustrialisation.
Sans réindustrialisation,
pas de salut ? Olivier Lluansi.
-La réponse est non. L'industrie,
ça apporte de la souveraineté.
Vous avez cité
un certain nombre de champs,
si vous avez pas
une industrie agroalimentaire,
une industrie de l'énergie, etc.,
vous n'avez pas de souveraineté.
Ca apporte quelque chose
qu'on sous-estime,
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement.
Quand il manque de l'amoxicilline
dans les pharmacies,
-Un antibiotique.
-Un antibiotique de base. Ca va pas
mettre la France à genoux...
-Il y a des gens qui vont mourir.
-Non, pas forcément,
mais vous allez soigner moins bien
et vous instillez
un doute de la part de la population
sur la capacité de votre outil
à délivrer des biens de base.
Ce doute-là, il a
un effet politique, citoyen,
beaucoup plus puissant.
On a parlé d'environnement,
il y aura la partie
des comportements à changer,
la partie des solutions
technologiques. Sans industrie,
nous ne déploierons pas
les solutions à la bonne échelle.
Dernier point,
qui est pour moi le premier,
la cohésion territoriale.
L'OCDE a sorti un chiffre
qui peut être contesté,
mais la France est le 1er pays
sur la décennie 2006-2016,
à avoir concentré la création
de richesse dans ses métropoles.
80 % de notre création de richesse
aurait été faite
dans les métropoles.
Les 2 pays européens suivants
sont particuliers,
le Danemark et l'Irlande, des pays
monométropole,
donc un effet capitale.
Celui qui vient après
à moins de 60 %,
c'est le Royaume-Uni qui nous
ressemble un peu. On a une politique
services post-industrielle
et de concentration de la richesse
dans les métropoles.
Il faut pas s'étonner d'avoir
des mouvements dans les territoires.
L'industrie permet de remettre
des emplois qualifiés,
faire le lien avec la transition
digitale et environnementale.
-Merci. Boris Ravignon.
-Je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec Olivier
Lluansi. Je viens d'un territoire
où on aime toujours l'industrie.
Il y en a encore beaucoup
dans notre pays
où il y a une vraie passion
pour l'industrie.
Comment faire pour que
cette transition énergétique
qu'on va, qu'on doit réaliser,
pour les raisons climatiques
qu'on a tous indiquées,
profite à nos territoires ?
C'est vraiment ça, le sujet.
Il y a des conditions
au niveau européen.
Le fait d'avoir par exemple
un cadre qui permette de conduire
une politique industrielle
au niveau européen
et de protéger le marché européen.
Il y a ensuite, il ne faut pas
l'oublier, Anne Lauvergeon l'a
démontré en creux sur le nucléaire,
finalement,
il faut une politique de filière.
Il faut arriver à renouer avec
des politiques et des stratégies
de filière, avec de la cohérence,
et d'agir dans le temps.
Il y a encore notamment plein
de sujets qui ne sont pas réglés,
parce que 2050,
c'est proche et relativement loin.
La capture et le stockage
de carbone, par exemple,
ça, c'est des sujets
qui technologiquement ne sont pas
réglés. Il faut mettre le paquet
pour profiter de cette option.
Sur l'hydrogène,
je crois là encore aujourd'hui
qu'il y a plein de choses
qui ne sont pas arrêtées et que
c'est précisément en investissant
maintenant qu'on a une petite chance
de peser sur les choix
qui seront faits. Ca va être
la même chose sur l'éolien.
L'éolien terrestre,
mais l'éolien marin, notamment
flottant, voilà une filière dans
laquelle la France a aujourd'hui
des positions assez intéressantes.
Poussons-la pour que demain,
en Méditerranée, on puisse
développer des éoliennes flottantes.
Il y a encore plein d'options
à prendre.
-Question annexe, mais comme
vous êtes un élu de l'Est,
une petite question.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
sur la reconversion
de Fessenheim, qui était
une centrale nucléaire
qui a été arrêtée ?
Juste...
-Je crois
que les collectivités locales ont
créé un certain nombre d'outils.
On a défini des espaces qui étaient
promis à la réindustrialisation.
Et puis, il y a eu beaucoup
de contraintes réglementaires
et donc, là où on avait des dizaines
d'hectares à réutiliser,
on s'est retrouvé
avec beaucoup moins.
Il y a un vrai sujet. On rejoint,
si on aime l'industrie, si on veut
qu'elle se redéploie, elle doit
trouver des espaces. La reconversion
des friches, dans l'Est, on en a
beaucoup, c'est un boulevard
pour redéployer nos industries.
-Merci, Boris Ravignon.
Le temps écoulé est passé.
C'est un sujet passionnant,
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler.
Je voudrais vous rappeler
une bibliographie
qui a servi
à préparer cette émission.
Anne Lauvergeon,
dans le temps, vous avez publié
"La femme qui résiste",
ce qui vous correspond.
Est-ce que vous préparez...
-Modestement.
-Vous préparez un ouvrage ?
-Oui, je prépare quelque chose
pour l'an prochain,
une promesse à François Mitterrand
que je vais accomplir.
-Christian Saint-Etienne,
je rappelle que votre dernier livre
était sur le conflit sino-américain
pour la domination mondiale.
-Il y a une double guerre mondiale.
Il y a une guerre géostratégique
entre la Chine et les Etats-Unis
et une guerre géoéconomique pour
la domination du monde numérique.
Les Chinois et les Américains
dominent 100 % des grandes
plateformes mondiales.
On parle souvent des licornes,
ils dominent aussi 80 % des licornes
mondiales en capitalisation.
Ces 2 pays qui font
43 % du PIB mondial assurent
60 % des dépenses militaires.
C'est vraiment géant.
Quand on voit une Europe ouverte
à tous les vents, on est inquiet.
-Merci pour ces chiffres édifiants.
Olivier Lluansi, vous avez
publié "Les néo-industriels"
aux éditions Déviation.
En deux mots, c'est quoi,
ces néo-industriels ?
-On vient de le dire.
On change de paradigme
environnemental et géopolitique,
on doit reconstruire
une nouvelle industrie.
Donc projetons-nous en 2040
et demandons-nous :
quels auront été les acteurs,
les chefs d'entreprise,
quelles auront été
leurs motivations,
qui nous auront permis
cette renaissance
industrielle.
-Merci à vous.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP.
Et avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette citation : "La priorité
de la France devrait être
"l'accélération
de la préparation aux choix
"que nous n'allons pas
manquer de subir plutôt
"que la recherche hypothétique
d'une position
"de surplomb."
C'est une pensée de Thomas Gomart,
qui est le président de l'IFRI.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA